Jennifer starts off this hour in Raleigh
North Carolina hi Jennifer how are you
good I'm a few days better than I
deserve what's up
hi I'm well my husband and I are on baby
step 2 we stay off about $30,000 myself
about 25,000 left to go to Italy by next
year way to go
so our situation is my mother recently
got arrested for stealing from her work
and got fired subsequently so she has no
job and no money we had priorly cut her
off about in March and she jumps are you
cut her off and marks right from
financial so you have been giving her
money right for the past eight or nine
years and say wow and pry and you did
not know at that time about the
embezzlement no I didn't um so this was
complete shock when this happened but
now you know I'm kind of in a situation
where you know do do we stick to our
guns and you know keep the mantras not
giving you a room or money or do a
helper absence you know her rince
becoming dude in a couple of days and
she has normal money for food or gas you
go to any type interview on the define
new job
that's time when was she when when when
when was she fired and when did they
discover the embezzlement about two
weeks ago and how much did she steal
about $1,500 Wow
and they're prosecuting her eyes oh yes
her file is not till December so you
know she has some time until she's
actually you know convicted I guess you
would say impossible even to the time I
don't know she has an attorney that's
been appointed to her gender yeah a
public dinner
are they going to plea-bargain this or
do you know I don't know yet I think she
just got a sign last week
okay so she's out he admitted it she
admitted it to the police so hopefully
that will help her out in some way shape
or form so what is her state of mind
does she feel like she's entitled to
help from you is she repentant is she
broken is she arrogant is she angry is
she afraid what system I don't I don't
think she's she thinks she's entitled to
it but I had been receiving text
messages over the past couple days you
know amount of money I'm out of gas and
I mean how kind of thing I haven't I
mean regarding all of this misbehavior
that is her life I mean she screwed up
in the handling of her money for years
right and she died and then she went so
far as to be a thief and so what is her
response to all of that is it like I've
hit rock bottom I'm ready to change or
is it like oh well those people have
plenty of money they could do without it
and and you're my daughter and you
should take care of me or what what is
your state of mind no it doesn't last
one but I don't think she's ten
realization of she's hit rock bottom
either because it's just a continuous
cycle I think was you know not having
any money and just kind of hoping that
somewhere bail her out but I don't think
she thinks that it was you know they
have a lot of money so it's okay to
steal from them um she does not know she
doesn't think that so she's remorseful
she is remorseful but I don't know if
it'll ever change her money habits and
you know unwillingness to be responsible
for herself well I think it's an act of
love to force her to do that on and that
and so my point being that if she if I'm
going to help her in this situation and
this is a really tough situation for you
because she's going to literally be
penniless shortly and um
you know it's really really tough for
you so if I'm in this situation I might
do something like pay your light bill
and maybe buy some food and take it to
her that kind of a thing and I might
actually fill the car up with gas and
then even those things and but in
certainly anything beyond that I'm going
to require behavior change out of her as
a part of any continued help I'm not
going to participate with someone who's
not remorseful not repentant repentance
means to turn away from and so they're
going to turn away from you know these
bad things because otherwise you are
financing things you don't believe in
right and I and the reason you don't
believe in them is they're not good for
her not because you're a tight water
you're a miser or you're selfish is none
of that it's you're not going to finance
the you know her misbehavior for her
sake I'm not going to participate in her
insanity so that that is an act of love
it feels strange when you're doing it
but you're going to have to sit down
with her and say mom you know you really
have been screwing off for a long time
here
and now now it's going to get you put in
jail and so you need to be on your face
in the floor crying out to God saying
forgive me and to the people you've
harmed saying forgive me and I'm willing
to change I'm willing to do anything
different from this point forward in my
life because my life is a mess right and
if you can't get to the place that
you're that willing to change our help
to you is going to be very very limited
because not because we want you to feel
bad but because we want you to change
for your sake and it's time for you to
transform your life and I would plug her
into a good church I would walk with her
and coach her I would encourage her but
even then you can't force someone to hit
bottom and you can't force them to be
willing to change
oh I guess my question is you know how
long should we I don't know
keep this out not a long long time I'm
saying I'm gonna my help is going to be
very limited in amount and in length of
time but now if she engages in positive
direction and you have some money and
you can reinforce that positive
direction by helping her with that thing
you know like she really gets a job
she's going crazy she does a plea
bargain here she turns this around part
of her plea bargain is going to be that
she repays this I'm sure there has to be
restitution made and I'll be shocked if
it's otherwise and so you know you okay
mom you put together the 750 bucks we'll
put 750 with it and you can get this
paid off and get it out from over your
head okay mom you want to do this will
do this will match you will come in and
help you with this and and you can do a
few things there depending on what your
budget allows but you can't just throw
money at people who will not change
there's not enough money on the planet
to help them and you're not helping them
you're participating in their insanity
you're not helping them get dignity
you're not helping them have a future so
she has to be moving in that direction
for you to continue this is the Dave
Ramsey show